As a preparation for more
complex and more difficult
models, we will start by
looking at the simplest model
that there is, that
involves a linear relation
and normal random variables.
The specifics of the
model are as follows.
There's an unknown parameter
modeled as a random variable,
Theta, that we wish to estimate.
What we have in our hands is
Theta plus some additive noise,
W. And this sum is
our observation,
X. The assumptions
that we make are
that Theta and W are
normal random variables.
And to keep the
calculations simple,
we assume that they're standard
normal random variables.
Furthermore, we assume
that Theta and W
are independent of each other.
According to the Bayesian
program, inference about Theta
is essentially the calculation
of the posterior distribution
of Theta if I tell you that
the observation, capital
X takes on a specific
value little x.
To calculate this
posterior distribution,
we invoke the appropriate
form of the Bayes rule.
We have the prior of Theta.
It's a standard normal.
Now we need to figure out
the conditional distribution
of X given Theta.
What is it?
If I tell you that the random
variable, capital Theta,
takes on a specific
value, little theta, then
in that conditional
universe, our observation
is going to be that specific
value of Theta, which
is our little theta,
plus the noise term,
capital W. This is the
relation that's holds
in the conditional
universe, where
we are told the value of Theta.
Now W is independent of Theta.
So even though I have told
you the value of Theta,
the distribution of
W does not change.
It is still a standard normal.
So X is a standard normal
plus a constant theta.
What that does is
that it changes
the mean of the
normal distribution,
but it will still be a
normal random variable.
So in this conditional
universe, X
is going to be a
normal random variable
with mean equal to
theta, and with variance
equal to the variance of
W, which is equal to 1.
So now, we know what
this distribution is,
and we can move with the
calculation of the posterior.
So we have the denominator
term, which I'm writing here.
And then we have the
density of Theta.
Since it is a
standard normal, it
takes the form of a constant.
We do not really care about
the value of that constant.
What we care really is
the term on the exponent.
And then we have the
conditional density of X
given Theta, which is a
normal with these parameters.
And therefore, it takes the
form c e to the minus 1/2.
It's a density in x.
And so, up here, we have x
minus the mean of that density.
But the mean is equal
to theta, squared.
And this is the final form.
Now what we notice here is that
we have a few constant terms.
Another term that depends on x,
and then a quadratic in theta.
So we can write all this as
some function of x, and then
e to the negative of
some quadratic in theta.
Now when we're doing inference,
we are given the value of X.
So let us fix a particular
value of little x
and concentrate on the
dependence on theta.
So with x being fixed,
this is just a constant.
And as a function of theta,
it's e to the minus something
quadratic in theta.
And we recognize that
this is a normal PDF.
So we conclude that the
posterior distribution
of Theta, given our
observation, is normal.
Since it is normal, the expected
value of this conditional PDF
will be the same as the
peak of that the PDF.
And this would be our
point estimate of Theta
in particular.
If we use either of the
MAP-- Maximum A Posterior
Probability-- or the least
mean squares estimator,
which is defined as the
conditional expectation
of Theta, given the
observation that we have made.
So this conditional
expectation is just
the mean of this
posterior distribution.
It is also the peak of that
So let us find what the peak is.
To find the peak, we focus
on the exponent term, which
is ignoring the minus sign,
the exponent term is this one.
And to find the peak
of the distribution,
we need to find the place where
this exponent term is smallest.
To find out when this
term is smallest,
we take its derivative
with respect to theta
and set it equal to 0.
The derivative of
this term is theta.
The derivative of this
term is theta minus x.
We set this to 0.
And when we solve this equation,
we find 2 theta equal to x.
Therefore, theta
is equal to x/2.
And so, we conclude
from here that the peak
of the distribution occurs
when theta is equal to x/2.
And this is our
estimate of theta.
So our estimate
takes into account
that we believe that
theta is 0 on the average.
But also takes into account the
observation that we have made,
and comes up with a value that's
in between our prior mean,
which was 0, and the
observation, which is little x.
So this is what
the estimates are.
If we want to talk about
estimators, which are now
random variables,
what would they be?
The estimator is
a random variable
that takes this value
whenever capital X takes
the value of little x.
Therefore, it's the
random variable,
which is equal to capital X/2.
This is a relation
between random variables.
This is a corresponding
relation between numbers
if you're given a specific
value for little x.
How special is this example?
It turns out that the same
structure of the solution
shows up even if we assume
that Theta and W are
independent normal
random variables,
but with some general
means and variances.
You should be able
to verify on your own
by repeating the calculations
that we just carried out
that the posterior distribution
of Theta will still be normal.
And since it is normal, the
peak of the distribution
is the same as the
expected value.
So the expected value, or
least mean squares estimator,
coincides with the maximum
a-posteriori probability
estimator.
And finally, although
this formula will not
be exactly true, there
will be a similar formula
for the estimator,
namely the estimator
will turn out to be a linear
function of the measurements.
We will see that these
conclusions are actually
even more general than that.
And this is what makes
it very appealing
to work with normal random
variables and linear relations.